welcome to this video playing Abby rule
check from Russia I guess good old
Budapest where i play my my sight line
here with night age three i have very
nice score with it so i see no reason to
to go away from that oops okay i try to
you must my opponent before that was
sending me a message i wanted to reply
briefly but it's not locked on anymore
ok so this type of position i had before
in this line oh this is ok that still ok
said okay but be three the still night
c4m
yeah whoopee one wasn't a very very
lucky move but bit superficial I wanted
to get out of the long diagonal but it
runs into yeah this which is not a
problem but still be one is not not
really helping me up queen t to Bishop
g5 would be nice nice to get in ya know
Bishop g5 is getting a really
problematic what if what are you doing
III jaan was what what is there the
defense against it should g5 III m
remarkable
no this is simply not doing anything
against this 90 f 6 now is some [ __ ] the
problem check him let's let's win this
this this material here not think about
it to know if I take yet Queenie a does
even 97 winning another exchange check
mm yeah well I still I still think I
take it you can take the rukon be one
but
yeah isn't here Bishop Bishop f6 and
Queen h6 isn't this quite good it
probably is young okay okay can you give
us a check windy five is also nice but
ok I'll play the simplest possible take
this pond just take this pawn and take
the bishop that this is an extra corn
and two bishops against two nights and a
bed king just them just to keep it
simple I am
so f for all there should be three I
probably should be three yeah probably
had something better but I wanted to
keep it simple as mentioned
preparing f4 and then at the end this
Bishop e3 must be regrouped on the long
diagonal why this should end the game
gets going right into the long diagonal
yeah move the night bishop deform
yeah two bishops against two nights one
of those cases where you see why bishops
are sometimes better
now this first this maybe even even
stronger
check
yeah filter to to find the media mmm
that's really not grading it's still
very good to everything but I really
think the game should should have ended
already probably some bad move order
you
you
we acted really weird Queen takes I've
rookie seven Queen f4 I mean every g7
okay if we trade them I play the same
game but still fields I should have firm
check should have found the major you've
got Bishop see one it's a this was so
check this was so I was really winning
anything you could have tried the
endgame check check check mate yeah how
do I win this this really quicker with
mate I mean here I really don't ok this
is jesse stronger this is stronger just
check getting a piece to f6 and then
play b5 with bishop d for coming ok this
was the way to do it okay this is also
quite good in fact computers giving plus
in check plus 11 again plus 12 yeah okay
it it probably is a window matter water
so it's simply too bad with the two
bishops against everything it was really
strange that he totally ignored Bishop
g5 I mean here you can play Knight f7
for example and this is ok White has a
bit
all play in the center and everything
but it's not a loss here and this this
is just just terrible after this at here
III I thought fighting some are somehow
try to to irritate me but here I'm just
totally winning check check maybe there
was something better even f4 is stronger
f form now ok this is really enough ok
thanks for watching